[Music]
well parents still have many questions
as the upcoming school year fast
approaches thank you for joining us
tonight at 11 i'm brian loftis ccsd
students start
full-time distance education on august
24th and district leaders address
concerns tonight
at a virtual town hall orco mana joining
us live in the newsroom with more on
what exactly was discussed
orco well brian the school year for ccsd
students is now less than two weeks away
the district has laid out more details
about what everyone can expect
and while some parents are not confident
in the plan others remain
optimistic and once i realized that
they're actually just going online
i immediately had to pull the trigger
ava musicon just took her son out of the
clark county school district saying
ccsd's at home learning model will not
be effective
my biggest fear was to have 30 kids in
front of a computer try to manage that
if you can't do it in a classroom so
there's plenty concerns i'll be honest
we're going to make mistakes but we're
going to learn from it and get better
ccsd superintendent dr jesus jarrah and
trustee deanna wright addressing parents
concerns tuesday during a virtual town
hall
one major worry keeping kids engaged i
don't expect and i don't think anybody
does
expects that kids will be on the
computer for six hours and 11 minutes
there'll be an opportunity for
independent work as well small group
instruction when it comes to chromebook
access
trustee wright highlighted a new
statewide family support center that
will help connect kids to internet and
devices
we're going to make sure that that kids
have those things so that they can have
education starting on the first day of
school some parents have
faith in what's to come i'm optimistic
that the kids will step up and that
those
parents will also come together
but they understand challenges lie ahead
disruption is without question
upon us there will also be a learning
hotline set up to help students if
they're struggling with school
we have more information about that as
well as internet and device access
on our website eight news now dot com